in aviation terms the uk's hotel
quarantine plan has been on
final approach for nearly three weeks
now and it was first announced back in
mid-january
10 days and 11 nights of enforced hotel
quarantine
now await anyone who has passed through
one of the 33 countries on the
government's red list
but london's heathrow airport said it
had yet to receive what it called
necessary reassurances an airport
spokesman warned of significant gaps in
the implementation of the plan
and the union representing some of the
security staff is equally concerned
about the transfer process from airport
to hotel
what does that process look like what
ppe is going to be available
for those workers what is expected
of those guards once they get to the
hotels now you have to bear in mind that
these travelers they're not
in custody the uk government says its
hotel quarantine plan amounts to
decisive action against kovitt 19.
but even as the first arriving
passengers go into enforced confinement
there is strong criticism of the way the
policy is being operated
and enforced inbound passengers need to
show a negative test
just to board an aircraft and pre-booked
two further tests for the days after
arrival
lying on a passenger locator form now
carries a 10-year prison sentence
ministers have spent the past week
talking up the plan
we have amongst the toughest border
regimes anywhere in the world
but doubts persist australian states
introduced hotel quarantine in march
2020
and have learned tough lessons since
then procedures on meal delivery times
ventilation staff testing and protective
masks
have all evolved significantly yet the
state of victoria is now back under
lockdown
after an outbreak of the virus spread
within this quarantine hotel
australian infection experts say the uk
needs to be
ultra cautious i'm nervous about what i
know about the uk system
it's good to know that smokers will not
be allowed to leave their rooms but
they're still allowed to leave their
rooms for exercise
we learned very much the hard way that
that just
doesn't work the government says
its policies are based on best practice
that may not be good enough paul brennan
al jazeera
heathrow airport